The brain is,
has specialized subsystem,
but dynamic biological systems so you
can muck about with it quite a bit and
it'll set itself up in
slightly different ways.
So the systems aren't
necessarily localized exactly
the same place in every one.
But roughly speaking,
everyone has those systems
and roughly speaking,
they're in the same place across people.
Now there's a lot of variability and it's
one of the things that makes you know,
Mri studies in the life very difficult
to interpret because if you average
across a lot of people,
what it means is you're blur things out,
you know,
cause you can only extract out what the
commonalities and although you know,
they're getting better and
better at dealing with that,
so.
Okay.
So
there's other ways that you
can think about the brain too.
These are all approaches
to understanding it.
You know,
there,
I would,
I would say it's a very,
very complex thing.
In fact,
it's the most complex thing near it.
You know,
there are more patterns of combinations
of neural connections in your brain.
Then there are subatomic
particles in the universe.
So you are,
I know you,
you won't believe that cause
it doesn't seem possible.
But you can do the math and you'll
figure out that it's actually write it.
So you're the most complicated
thing there is and by a lot.
And so in some sense there's
more space inside your head.
Then there is space outside your head.
It depends on how you conceptualize space,
you know,
because you can conceptualize space as
the number of ways that something can be
configured and that
state space and that's a,
that's a magnitude measurement,
you know,
and the distance between things,
well that's another way
of conceptualizing space.
But if you're wanting,
if you want to think about big,
what's inside you is,
I think that it's bigger
than what's outside.
You would certainly that
way in terms of complexity,
unless you factor in the
other brains know so.
So that's very much worth thinking
about means that you know,
what we don't understand about
the brain is going to fill many,
many books.
And one of the things we really
don't understand his consciousness,
people just don't get that.
And it doesn't really look,
you know,
you might think that consciousness is
an emergent late evolutionary function,
you know,
but it doesn't really look like that,
you know?
I mean,
when even when people become demented and,
and they,
you lose almost all of their
higher cortical function.
There's no doubt there's still conscious.
And so consciousness might be way,
way,
way older than we think.
And in fact,
I think it's highly probable.
I don't think a hypothalamic
cat is unconscious.
It's certainly a wake,
you know,
and distinguishing between awake
and conscious is no easy thing.
You might say,
well,
animals aren't conscious.
It's like,
well,
you know,
here's the thing.
You know,
what people norm normally think is that
humans are different than other animals.
And so before you
anthropomorphize an animal,
you should be careful.
But I think that's complete rubbish.
I think it's exactly the opposite.
Before you assumed that humans
have attributes that animals don't,
you have to prove it
because there's continuity,
tremendous,
tremendous continuity.
And so it's right to
anthropomorphize animals.
What's wrong is to presume a priority
that humans are qualitatively different.
Now,
there are some very
bizarre things about us.
Obviously,
you know these,
we have opposable thumbs.
That's a big deal.
We can grip things.
That's a massive deal,
you know,
and it turns out that there's another,
your,
your brain maps your body onto
its surface onto its motor strip,
and it's sensory strip,
which are roughly here on the brain.
And if you take the motor strip or
the sensory strip and you make a
representation of how
it represents the body,
which is called a Homerun,
keyless wielder,
Penfield wilder Penfield still did
this first at McGill university.
He,
I don't know if you know this and
perhaps you'll be fortunate enough to
experience it,
but people who have brain surgery
are conscious when it happens.
And that's so that the surgeons can figure
out whether this little part is doing
anything important
before they take it out.
You know,
it's a very horrific thought.